noi siamo bianco valente siamo degli
artisti visivi e per oggi volevamo
invitarvi a fare una riflessione
sull'importanza della parola stiamo
parlando di converse action e la parola
è un evento veramente importante
considerato che fra gli esseri viventi
siamo gli unici che abbiamo una capacità
di comunicazione così elaborato proprio
attraverso la parola e la parola e la
storia è una delle cose è fondamentale
nella nostra vita pensate solo questo
la nostra evoluzione ha portato il
nostro cervello a svilupparsi in modo da
cercare di acquisire informazioni
dall'esterno sotto forma di parola di
racconto noi siamo dei bambini piccoli
siamo stanchissimi stiamo per prendere
sonno eppure pretendiamo che nostra
madre nostro padre ci racconti una
storia perché ancora noi non sappiamo
legge però restiamo affascinati da
questo da questo racconto dopo di che
diventiamo più grandi cominciamo a
sfogliare questi libri dove le parole
sono non ci sono parole ci sono immagini
però c'è questo senso della storia e noi
serve siamo proprio
abbiamo bisogno di storie ok poi
diventano più grandi cominciamo a
leggere oppure cominciano a guardare la
televisione e lì ci vengono proposte
altre storie poi leggiamo i libri e sono
delle storie andiamo al cinema perché ci
vengono raccontate altre storie quindi
perché è così importante da questa cosa
io vi racconto questo anch'io vi
racconto una storia adesso è una storia
che risale alla notte dei tempi
probabilmente immaginate un un villaggio
di una prima comunità umana noi ci
parliamo la parola ci permette di
scambiarci informazioni emozioni c'è un
gruppo di persone di questo di questa
piccola comunità di questo villaggio si
allontana perché va caccia perché va a
recuperare del cibo per nutrire tutta la
comunità un'altra parte della comunità
resta al villaggio quando dopo due
giorni il giorno stesso dopo tre giorni
queste persone tornano se sono state
fortunate se sono riusciti a cacciare
degli animali portano la carne e questa
terna il cibo per il corpo delle persone
che compongono questa comunità però non
solo quello portano anche le storie loro
si sono allontanate dal villaggio hanno
visto altre cose hanno corso dei
pericoli sono successe delle cose
incredibili poi ovviamente
per rendersi più belli raccontano anche
altre cose quindi mentre si prepara
questa carne mentre la si mangia insieme
ci si scambia le proprie esperienze ho
visto questo ho vissuto ho vissuto
questa cosa ma anche le persone sono
rimaste al villaggio raccontano le
proprie storie quello che è successo
quello che ne hanno visto e la parola
una cosa importante vedete non c'è
neanche un immagine su questo schermo
quando una persona parla solo tramite la
parola alla capacità di indurre la
formazione di immagini mentali nella
mente le altre persone che quello che
sta avvenendo adesso
per questo diciamo noi siamo artisti
visivi ma da molti anni abbiamo scoperto
l'importanza della parola e del racconto
il racconto quel gruppo sociale di cui
parlavamo prima si tiene insieme proprio
grazie allo scambio di queste storie
quello che tiene unite quello che tiene
unita una comunità non è una bandiera il
confine che viene fortificato col muro
non è un monumento le persone possono
riconoscersi in quello ma soprattutto si
riconoscono alle storico che hanno in
comune quello la cosa fondamentale è non
lavoriamo con questo
si è la parola e le storie come diceva
prima pino sono delle cose fondamentali
per noi
da un po di anni abbiamo cominciato a
lavorare in maniera molto approfondita
su questo tema ed è per questo che
spesso ci troviamo a lavorare con delle
comunità creando delle opere d'arte
pubblica che coinvolgono appunto delle
persone attraverso le storie di queste
persone noi creiamo delle installazioni
intrecciando appunto memoria storie di
esperienze
un esempio è un lavoro che abbiamo fatto
a new york nel 2014 che si chiama
costellazione di me si chiama
costellazioni di me e dove appunto
abbiamo coinvolto diverse persone e
l'intento era quello di raccontare le
profonde trasformazioni che ha subito un
quartiere il quartiere cessi che tutti
forse conoscete che in 30 anni e si è
trasformato in quartiere
portuale di industriale al quartiere
dove c'è un'altissima concentrazione
galleria infatti diventato un centro per
l'arte contemporanea molto importante e
dove ci sono
ristoranti negozi di lusso eccetera
quindi c'è stata c'è stato questo
passaggio fondamentale da quartiere
popolare anche industriale a quartiere
di lusso quindi cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo incontrato delle persone in
gruppo di pensionati che vivono ancora
gli accessi ad un sito molto basso
perché hanno appunto questi questi
affitti bloccati che però ci
raccontavano sono costretti ad andare in
altri quartieri per fare la spesa
semplicemente per andare a comprare beni
di prima necessità
proprio perché lì i prezzi sono
diventati altissimi e attraverso queste
storie attraverso la memoria che loro
hanno di questo luogo abbiamo creato
un'installazione
che loro sono venuti poi a realizzare
insieme a noi scrivendo le loro storie
di proprio pugno nella galleria dove poi
abbiamo realizzato quest'opera
intrecciando insieme queste storie
abbiamo creato un'installazione fatta di
linee di parole tutte intrecciate
insieme ed ogni linea di parole
rappresentava la storia di ognuno di
loro
quindi quando entrava in galleria vedevi
praticamente immaginate una linea che
parte da quell'angolo sale così gira a
scendere l'altro lato e queste persone
sono venute in galleria è una cosa
inusuale perché un giorno in galleria ci
lavora all'artista si tratta di lavorare
invece noi abbiamo chiesto in una prima
settimana di laboratori abbiamo che se
loro ci raccontassero dal professore
all'inizio sembra strano perché non ti
conoscono reazione non si fidano e
quindi come abbiamo fatto come si fa
sempre hanno cominciato a raccontare noi
le nostre storie si sono appassionati e
piano piano ce le hanno ce le hanno
raccontate dopodiché abbiamo detto
questo lavoro sia una costellazione di
me ma non è di me ho di lei e di lui e
di lui noi vediamo che attraverso la
storia di tutti voi non riusciamo a
raccontare la storia di dei cambiamenti
di questo quartiere che questa è la cosa
più importante
la comunità il quartiere è fatto le
persone che ci vivono e quindi poi i
primi giorni abbiamo abbiamo imparato a
conoscerci poi piano piano sono uscite
le storie poi abbiamo scoperto che
avevano timore di scrivere perché avevo
paura di fare errori ortografici e torna
non ci interessano e noi ci interessa lo
spirito della tua storia dopodiché
quando ci hanno raccontato queste storie
abbiamo portato una ma una mappa di new
york è ingrandita sul quartiere chelsea
abbiamo detto che voi avete raccontato
delle storie
forse segnano i punti di dove sono
avvenute queste storie e allora sono
detto ma non esistono più questi luoghi
sono sono trasformati e tornare
importanza che quel luogo stava qui un
altro statali e quindi sono uscite una
serie di punti queste storie ognuno era
localizzato in un punto diverso
anche per questo sia una costellazione
di me quando siamo andati in galleria
avevano due pareti ad angolo e abbiamo
riportato questi muri in grande questi
punti ingrandendoli su questi due muri e
su questi punti abbiamo cominciato a
disegnare la costellazione fatta delle
storie di queste persone ed è stata una
cosa bellissima perché laurent anziani
però comunque sono arrampicati sulla
scala ovviamente poi in alto i nostri
siano andati noi a scrivere a continuare
a trascurare lo store e per a loro e per
loro è stata un'emozione grandissima e
quando entrava nella sala tu arrivi una
rete cioè sembrava un disegno una cosa
di grafica e invece poi quando ti
avvicinavi
incominciato a guardare tutte queste
linee di scrittura di questi intrecci e
tutte le storie che hanno vissuto lì e
hanno vissuto i cambiamenti di di questo
quartiere se volete vedere le immagini
andato a cercarle sul nostro sito ma
credo che vi saranno riempite elementi
di immagini grazie grazie